[Música]
[Aplausos]
hiperconectividad hipermovilidad big
data bots crowdfunding block change
sino contra esta terminología si no
utilizan la huella dactilar para
conectarse a algo si no transmitimos en
vídeo los paseos con el perro o no
transmitimos por twitter lo que estamos
haciendo o no tenemos la grabadora
conectada al móvil entonces en ese caso
no se entiende muy bien para qué
existimos
no seré yo quien frivolice con lo
digital todo lo contrario esta
revolución que nos ha sobrevenido es
mucho más que una revolución económica
es una revolución social e incluso una
revolución cognitiva mucho más de lo que
la mayoría de los mortales podemos
asimilar quiere decir esto que estamos
sumidos en una vorágine tecnológica que
amenaza a devorarlo todo
no solo no lo creo sino que defiendo
todo lo contrario la revolución digital
traerá un mundo nuevo y mejor si la
humanidad es capaz de trascender
evolucionando en lo social
y en lo personal
pero esta evolución no será posible sino
un cambio importante de actitud hacia lo
digital y la clave de este cambio sólo
podrá venir de la mano de la solidaridad
intergeneracional
pero antes de seguir con esto me
gustaría centrar dos conceptos primer
concepto el de nativo digital
seguramente la mayoría de ustedes lo han
oído pero puede que algunos no sepan que
fue acuñado allá por el año 2000 por
marc prensky para referirse a las
personas nacidas después de 1980
es decir la primera generación que
además de televisión y bicicleta tuvo en
la infancia acceso a internet y
ordenador personal en casa
como llama entonces prensky a los
nacidos antes de 1980 este es el segundo
concepto nos llama inmigrantes digitales
según brenes quin los nativos digitales
han desarrollado habilidades de
comunicación y de aprendizaje diferentes
a los de sus padres y abuelos
inmigrantes porque han estado sometidos
desde edades tempranas a estímulos
cognitivos diferentes el predominio de
las imágenes frente al texto el estímulo
de ciertos reflejos por los videojuegos
la hipertextualidad
por contra los inmigrantes digitales
hemos tenido que transitar por el mundo
digital utilizando nuestras viejas
herramientas leyendo para aprender
haciendo las cosas de manera secuencial
y volviéndonos locos cuando el
hipertexto no nos permitía volver al
documento que estábamos leyendo
originalmente
eso sin contar lo que nos costó aprender
a usar el ratón o la pantalla táctil que
nuestros hijos manejan como si fuera un
instinto
a la diferencia de competencias entre
inmigrantes y nativos digitales es lo
que se llama la brecha digital
llegamos a este punto
me gustaría desmontar tres creencias
ampliamente reygadas
primera creencia los jóvenes se mueven
como pez en el agua en todo lo que tiene
que ver con internet y las tecnologías
de la información y la comunicación
en realidad no es verdad es cierto que
deberían tener más fácil aprender estas
herramientas pero como de pequeños los
enviamos a la guardería a aprender a
leer les limitábamos el uso de los
videojuegos y les convencimos de que
esto de aprender era otra cosa difícil y
aburrida ahora es algo a lo que no
quieren dedicar su tiempo
no tiene no parece de recibo que un
estudiante universitario salga de la
facultad sin saber manejar con soltura
una hoja de cálculo o haciendo unas
presentaciones llenas de texto y sin
imágenes el manejo de las nuevas
aplicaciones tipo facebook o whatsapp no
es garantía de desenvolverse con soltura
en el mundo digital
segunda creencia
los mayores no han tenido oportunidad de
aprender las herramientas digitales y
por tanto les cuesta mucho trabajo
tampoco es verdad
el uso de los ordenadores de las
ofimática o de las aplicaciones de
gestión datan de los años 90 es decir de
hace casi 30 años
no creo que cualquier persona que haya
desarrollado su vida profesional en
empresas durante los últimos 30 años no
haya tenido la oportunidad de hacer un
curso o de manejar las herramientas de
manera autoridad
es cierto que nos costó aprender a usar
el ratón era un cambio cognitivo de esos
que hablaba aprendes que recuerdan pero
ahora nadie nos tiene que enseñar a
hacer zoom con dos dedos o hacernos un
self y
tercera creencia
a partir de cierta edad ya no hace falta
esforzarse con lo digital porque no es
necesario
tampoco es cierto la digitalización está
aquí para quedarse no sabemos cómo va a
evolucionar pero lo que sí sabemos es
que hay un montón de tareas que
actualmente hacen las personas y que
pronto solo las harán las máquinas y
tendremos que saber utilizarlas ya hay
estaciones de metro totalmente
automatizadas en las que solo existen
máquinas expendedoras para comprar cómo
se las van a arreglar las personas
mayores
misma ahora tiene 88 años
y una enfermedad que le produce un
temblor en las manos que le dificulta
tareas cotidianas como cocinar escribir
etcétera eso limita bastante su
actividad y por eso hace tres años le
dimos un ipad lo recibió con toda suerte
de prevenciones porque según ella las
máquinas la odian
al principio le pusimos libros para que
leyese con comodidad
luego fotos de sus nietos y sus
bisnietos para que se distrajese
a continuación le abría una cuenta en
telegram para que compartías el chat con
mi marido mis hijos y sus parejas que
viven fuera ella no puede escribir pero
se mantiene al día de todas las
actividades familiares
actualmente y a pesar de su tormentosa
relación con siri tiene un perfil en
facebook con el que sigue a personas de
su familia y conocidos
lee el periódico y lleva el seguimiento
de su cuenta corriente por internet no
lo necesita ahora no se separa de su
ipad
en definitiva
el mundo digital ha llegado y estamos
inmersos en el somos inmigrantes pero no
tenemos un país al que volver si este
país no nos gusta
y por ello el manejarnos bien en este
país en este mundo digital en el que
además están nuestros hijos pasa por que
nos ayudemos mutuamente como dije antes
por la solidaridad intergeneracional
y cómo se materializa esta solidaridad
intergeneracional en este contexto
pues yo tengo un truco sencillo
con un nativo digital en tu vida
si es un hijo o una hija mejor
pero si no seguro que hay una sobrina un
vecino alguien a quien pedir ayuda
pregunta hasta la saciedad
recuerdas aquellas sesiones
interminables de por qué por qué por qué
por qué pues eso te lo deben
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pide ayuda
que te ayuden con el procesador de
textos con el facebook a hacer una web a
hacer una compra si sabe que te ayude y
si no sabe que aprenda contigo lo va a
necesitar muchísimo más que tú
en el año 2000 la empresa en la que
trabajaba abordó un importante proyecto
de mejora y a mí me tocó entre otras
cosas presentar los resultados a la
dirección en aquel entonces me contactó
con power point era limitado pero yo era
consciente de las posibilidades que
tenía para hacer una presentación de
impacto acababa de salir al mercado el
office 2000 y lo que yo no tenía era
tiempo para aprenderlo de manera
autodidacta
por aquel entonces mi hijo pequeño tenía
nueve años y por supuesto manejaba todos
los dispositivos digitales que le dieran
así que le enseñé la existencia del
powerpoint y le dio autorización a jugar
con él a condición de que en dos semanas
tenía que ayudarme con mi presentación
animaciones transiciones utilización de
imágenes
no voy a cantarles con los detalles pero
en tres días había conseguido hacer un
juego en el que diversas formas se
movían sorteaban obstáculos y además
había diferentes niveles de dificultad
no sé cómo lo hizo en aquel momento no
tuve tiempo de preguntarle cómo lo había
hecho pero lo que sí les puedo decir es
que mi presentación fue un éxito y que
buena parte de lo que hoy sé de power
point lo aprendí de un niño de 9 años no
lo duden para ellos es un juego y encima
les encanta demostrarnos que saben más
que nosotros
algo parecido a esto lo están utilizando
algunas empresas
para sus procesos de transformación
digital están utilizando lo que se llama
mentón en inverso personas jóvenes que
enseñan ayudan y acompañan a personas
mayores si funciona en un entorno
empresarial no debería funcionar mejor
donde hay una relación familiar o
afectiva
una buena parte de esta charla ha estado
dirigida principalmente a los
inmigrantes digitales a los nativos me
costará trabajo convencerles de que
necesitan a sus mayores para
desenvolverse en el mundo digital pero
sí que nos necesitan
por ejemplo muchos de los proyectos que
quieran abordar o que quieran poner en
marcha serán serán imposibles si los
inmigrantes no los entienden o no los
saben comprar o utilizar
por lo tanto no lo duden
si son inmigrantes les queda una larga
vida en la que seguir sacando partido a
lo digital
y si sois nativos os queda una vida aún
más larga en la que seguir diseñando
produciendo y vendiendo soluciones
digitales
ayudadnos a valorarlas
nos hace falta compartir el reto que
tenemos delante con la transformación
digital
todo lo que podamos hacer para ayudarnos
a otros para ayudarnos unos a otros será
en beneficio de una vida más productiva
ambos nos necesitamos y todos saldremos
ganando si nos ayudamos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]